hello
um I'm Joshua genesti today I'll be
presenting cats it's a it's an acronym
for Content addressable Transformers and
it's a reference implementation for a
POC that I'm working on
so cats is a Ada product
interoperability uh framework that
enables you to swap
data processing Frameworks like spark
desk
and other Frameworks like function as a
service for example
the workloads could be on multi-cloud
services and they provide data providers
it allows
multi-disciplinary teams to
work on data products using the entire
cloud service model
software as a service on top of platform
as a service on top
infrastructure as a service and it
processes polyglot
data results
to be operational and analytical on the
right hand side of the shape right here
the analytical data output would be the
result data on the analytical data plan
and these
bill of materials which is a supply
chain term I'm using has the operational
data which is a data provenance record
of ipfs cids similar to Git Version
history
teams could use the cids to verify data
processing during data Discovery as well
as transport and re-execute processes on
a network of
okay
so why are they useful okay
okay uh they increase
scaling and decentralized operations out
so they parallelize operation
between multi-disciplinary teams
within multi multiple business
organizations or just organizations
across business domains right the
domains would be cross-functional
dependent on the team
and I'll talk about that in the next
slide it increases operational
efficiency
uh it decentralizes
product ownership in such a way that the
business domains it enables it enables a
customer-centric approach
to implementing products with tighter
feedback loops for teams
I think you just
this is a illustration of how hey this
is spotify's this is Spotify okay you
can think of this as like a product on
Spotify but the
but the product see okay each of these
products is a business domain so a cat
would be used
each of these products are a business
domain so cats would each cat would be
kind of like a micro product
um that decentralizes a traditional
product involving
all of these domains so the O's
represent operational data that these
represents analytical data
the arrows between them represents
cats connected to each
other iPod a network
so in other words
the decentralized a monolithic product
by breaking it up into cross-functional
micro products between organizations or
on a network of pairs
so if tests were deployed a virtual
machine that appears on this network
uh it'll link these products implemented
on existing services like
okay so why do cats why do we use ipfs
for this so ipfs is a protocol a
peer-to-peer protocol for storing and
retrieving files right so
the technical term for
what actually EFS implements which
they're calling a CID is a Content
addressable storage so it's a method for
storing and retrieving location
that are unique cryptographic hashes
issue for you to files so in other words
the contents of the file are the same
the hash will be the same unless
otherwise
was right and
to my knowledge it's the only
it's the only content addressable
storage protocol
um that I'm aware of that can be used
with data verification and transport
which
the location agnostic Uris could be
collected into I would say updated
provenance record so essentially I'm
using ipfs
because
it can be stored and retrieved
using Uris but ipfs is in storage it's a
protocol so somebody would be
responsible for storing themselves okay
and I would say
data verification is only guaranteed
that the transformation or the data
process is deterministic
so if you're using random number number
generators
use a seed
otherwise a Hashem won't be the same I'm
sorry
so I keep on saying this word data
product
and that should Define it so it's a node
on a mesh Network that encapsulates the
components that function as a service
in a way that provides access to a
domain's analytical data as a product
so these components are code data
metadata and infrastructure
okay
the use case would be a
multi-disciplinary team
um
operating on
uh restricted domain
as with with with restricted business
domain and that business domain
put on the product so an example would
be like a data scientist or analyst
using this data transformation
interface
to be deployed as software to service a
software as a service with some
interoperable processing framework as
far
as a part of a tap process
so the processor
uh
across with process data using spark SQL
or data frame API or something
okay
and then there's a back end engineer or
machine learning engineer implementing a
cad application as software as a service
for the data scientists
deployed on
I don't know a managed kubernetes
service for example as platform for the
service right here and then the
infrastructure engineer would use
terrible infrastructure's code
yeah so it's kind of like
it's kind of like data driven design and
development similar to user-driven
design and development
and a data scientist can act as a micro
product owner
which alleviates the traditional product
owner's communication overhead
uh
due to user-driven development so so
they can focus on user driven design so
I can just slide above here
okay the analyst
and the traditional product would be
working closely together
right and the analysts or the data
scientists will inform
the
development of the product and the
design of the product directly
so
it puts them
it's like a communication Improvement
s
right so I'm using this term bill of
materials
okay
it's a data provenance record with ipf
scids so
um
yeah because it could store and retrieve
and
verifiable
so this bomb is the i o of cats
so the Transformer has a CID for the
you know whatever the analyst is
interface with
the CID there's this
concept of an invoice that I'm using
which is a Content address data set so
it's a collection of ipf scids and data
partitions and the Demo's case with the
spot data partitions
Edition which is used to be which is
being processed by spark yeah
so and I should say yeah data provenance
is just a type of data lineage with
historical records containing metadata
uh describing the means of processing
from source to destination but ipfs
provides the additional value of
being re-executed re-executable upon
retrieval so that's what I'm providing
for the cap has been put
okay so this is an example of
a data pipeline that uses these path as
I O
and they're linked by this bill of
materials URI
and mine I just I should make a joke
here this this is the supply chain it's
a data supply chain okay
oh
this is
so cat0 would be the initial content
address Transformer that produces the
initial Bond
and the
the bomb it produces would be given to a
cat which produces a subsequent data
provenance record
and so on and so on and this is an
example of header record for the entire
time that contains sequences of these
cids do we execute the entire pipeline
which probably should be a part of each
Bob
I consider that for the future
but you get the idea so these records
once they're on the network
well they established you're
establishing a network
and the operational data you are the
operational data Uris are used to
retrieve them so it's kind of cool
so cats was used
was designed with this principle it's
called an architectural quantum
it's a domain driven design principle
it's a small issue of architecture
independently
it's a smallest unit of architecture
that could independently be deployed
with high functional cohesion and
includes the structural elements
functional cohesion because there
because they're close together
um yeah I took this from Savannah
in this article data mesh principles
building driven design
so it enables data product
implementation with adapter okay
so
um okay so the action and control planes
are orthogonal movements of a node's IO
interface
okay so the action plane here
the action plane here is a collapsed
plane of let's say
the analytical or the analytical data
plane and the control plan in kubernetes
so it's a collapse plane so it's a
one-dimensional representation of
two-dimensional plane
in multi-cloud
control plane would be
would be the i o interface that Networks
so you're essentially connecting
a cloud there's a product built on the
cloud service model to a peer-to-peer
Network
so the planet infrastructure are
classifications of the node structural
elements
I'll explain what a plan is in the
future uh infrastructure
is self-explanatory processing and
precautions our classifications of the
no functional elements the process
would be the data transformation
interface
an analysts to a scientist or the
story that's deeper function is a
utility for the fire
which is a data transformation framework
in the process is performed by the data
transformation
in a way that adds value so I already
describe this
uh
yeah like I said
it's a tube it's a one-dimensional
represent the action plane is a
one-dimensional representation of the
operational
and data planes of a centralized cloud
it's the analytical data
it's uh did IO
the control pair playing this
decentralized peer-to-peer Networks
okay it's communication between cats
using cids
and governance and of the configuration
and policies on
uh
and I explain this but like an example
would be sparked as function of the
service Etc
interoperable
infrastructure as code with the
infrastructure
information API the computational
process SQL
Etc
looking for functions utilities this is
an example
of how the
components of this architectural Quantum
works as a you have a software password
that produces a
processor a constructs function
instructor
which were a components of the previous
design in a way that function runs or
executes on the structure structure
being
I don't know
kubernetes deployed on
kubernetes service and
AWS
okay
and it makes these reports
well it configures and reports about
these are views of the body same
see I believe that are
it's just a different View
everyone's stored
can be retrieved
these are the inputs
the function as opposed input data
structures code the factory uses that to
produce
and then execute the processor and then
you have your analytical data on the
right hand side
then uh right
all right so the top
the top half is the
top half is the infrastructure and I'm
using mini view right now okay so the
bottom half is just like
this is what I'll be demoing
the initial pack is
creating the initial bomb and the
subsequent cap is processing data on
network and producing a subsequent block
other cats this is like an example of
the transformation UI SQL
python data
okay
Okay so
I'll just explain this I should probably
I should explain this before I don't
know
all right
so this is an example of
cats kubernetes infrastructure
as an execution environment that is
instantiated on minicube like I said
earlier it could have been eks it
doesn't matter
so it uses it's an infra function that
uses who control to create a service
account for submitting Spock
applications by the user
which would be the analyst or data
scientist or
whoever's doing data transformation or
processing
cluster role by finding for namespaces
I don't know the cluster role cluster
namespace on kubernetes secret for AWS
just secrets for Access Control and
whatever
cloud service platform we're using so
that's all here and yeah Spock is a
Docker Imaging tool
I made a custom image into the ipfs
client on the image
that's the first part
and I'm not demoing that part because
every cat does the same thing or skips
it over and careful
Okay so
that happens on top here in this second
here
so this is an example of
an initial cat
jump calling cat zero using an
infrastructure
uh to execute
a cat syrup so it builds their podcast
software into a package it installs the
package on the driver's virtual
environment for podcasts it zips the
driver's virtual environment
it executes spark submit
and sends the virtual environment and
CAD application to work your nodes in a
spark class
so let me show you that
thank you
so I'm just executing the first step
so this is creating a virtual
environment
yeah
installing dependencies
zipping it
skip this
and it was the application that's
running was sent to
the application that running was sent to
containers
that are which sent the spark cluster
in kubernetes
so it's just distributed with the
application the virtual online
the kubernetes is setting up
infrastructure
to explain involved and now spark is
running
it's going to take a while skip this
and we'll show you the results yeah I
wanted to record this
um
I prefer to explain it ahead of time
to show you what
foreign
okay this is an example of the invoice
that I was describing
single partition so it's just a data set
with a CID
the partition itself and some metadata
these are Uris for the ipfs client
they're just locations of the ipfs
client
actually this is the
provenance record
so this High part cids this is a CID of
a single partition
this is the Bob CID
this is the URI and S3
but everything necessary to run with
such a good practice there
that can't produce
once modified okay so I've got a little
slide
yeah okay the only difference between
this cap and the previous cap
is now given the bomb that I just showed
you which is this one alpha bomb that
was just produced this cat is executing
on network so right now
the kubernetes cluster
because I'm not using
ipfs storage solution I have a cache
on the worker nodes of the spark cluster
that is ipfs Appliance so I keep the
cluster
ephemeral until
until I get a storage solution for okay
so all that's happening is
the Transformers ID if you get it from
the ipfs cache
and transfer it to the file system that
the
data processing framework is using
which is in this case a spark and that's
S3 it could be hdfs
and I don't know how to
you know use those Storage Solutions
with these Frameworks yet but we're
working on that okay
and then the track the transformation
the data process I don't know
let's say tabular data structure
stipulation like a
data frame
the transformation script that's
that transformation for this applied
okay the transformation is done
the data is uh
in this content address data set is
transferred to
um the file system
and
it's content identified
the output is content identified the
bottom is generated the invoice is
generated which is a Content addressed
data set and you produce a second
so I'll just
clue that works
let me show you what's in it
so I don't have to go through the
initial steps
because the infrastructure already
exists
actually I will show you that
okay that's the original data set
uh this bottom half
it's like all of the information that
changes which is like
ipfs clients Uris
yeah that's the result data set right
there it's just a language review
that's the original bomb
from the previous cat that was produced
by the previous cat
this is a subsequent
there's some other data
and uh
yeah I just want to thank these people
David Sison Michael zargo Jeff Emmett
Jeff Jessica Scotland Verrado and
nickana I would have been able to
do this without them okay
this is me
I've done
a lot of things
too many things
questions
see
you
thank you
even though
that's the environment
right
okay
foreign
I need that
yes
but anyway
s
that
is
interested
well
and back basically as far as here we go
is
surgery
oh yeah
okay
yes there is it's called cat on GitHub
it won't scroll down
okay yeah
there is a repo it's called cats
um right now it's on Ubuntu 20 before so
you'll have to run in a VM but it's
supposed to be running again
but not necessarily I have to
have to create a I have to I have to
import it to map once I do that you'll
be able to use it
um
yeah
this documentation
of this there's demo examples
to the examples of what I ran
is in here
yeah everything I demos it is I guess
you could just walk through this
okay
I'm left
it's it's
like a
it's just a it's a Google Concept um
I would say a data data scientists can
collaborate
with I don't know a machine learning
engineer and an infrastructure engineer
on it or you could do all of that this
is like me
not
weird
foreign
like
Iraq
secretary
of course
yeah there's a collaborative advice
[Music]
explain
Ed
by the time
yeah perfect
I wanna
be a little bit
or you can have another
important
perfect
if you don't have
very much
but the collaborators
foreign
excuse me
thank you
sir
yeah then again
quality
sir
is
applying change
architecture
level
s
lost
it
thank you